a homeless man is charged with the
murder of a college golf star in Iowa
this is the second high-profile murder
of a college student in the state this
year
Talia bar Kino Rose Amina was the
European ladies amateur champion the
Iowa State University student was killed
Monday Dean Reynolds is on Iowa State
University's campus where she was a
beloved student athlete Dean good
morning good morning this poster of
failure bar kina Rosalina hangs in the
main athletic building here in
recognition of her place in the school
sports history on Monday her golf clubs
were found abandoned on a local fairway
by another golfer who called 911 arose
Amenas life of promise was ended on a
public golf course in broad daylight by
a random act of violence
the 22 year olds body was found around
11:00 a.m. Monday in a pond near the
ninth tee at Coldwater Golf Links she
had been stabbed in the torso head and
neck she's so much I'm happy she just
had this great light about her Christie
Martins was her coach how are her
teammates taking this they're really
struggling you know she was really close
with them she's really special and I
really I love her a lot
Colin Daniel Richards the 22 year old
murder suspect briefly appeared in court
Tuesday with apparent scratches on his
face he's charged with first-degree
murder
police say a k-9 tracked the victim sent
to a nearby homeless camp where Richards
was staying they recovered a knife and
two pairs of bloody shorts a witness
also said the suspect who was released
from prison in June allegedly talked
about having an urge to rape and kill a
woman we have had encounters with him in
the past in barkins hometown in Spain
women wept in the streets and flags flew
at half-staff her brother Andres spoke
about the family's grief
we are all together trying to put
ourselves together he said bar Keene is
the reigning big 12 champion and Iowa
State's female athlete of the year she
was due to graduate with a degree in
civil engineering the day I went to
votes in Iowa I want to study
engineering and she was like go for it
it's all good
she took three classes taught by Jim
Allman she was sincere about her
education she wasn't just here to play
golf this morning the Des Moines
Register is reporting that Richards
defense attorney says his client will
plead not guilty
meanwhile Iowa State was planning to
honor bar Keene arosa maina's
achievements as well as herself on
Saturday that tribute will now go ahead
on Saturday but it will be a memorial
Nora so upsetting she's such a
remarkable young woman your heart breaks
with her family getting that call awful
very soon